votre vidéo vous est présenté par
victoria tirer talents.com vous avez
plus de 5000 follower sur vos réseaux
sociaux
venez nous rejoindre et devenez
influenceurs grâce à victoria tirer
talents.com
il ya deux cabines il y a un thème le
premier thème c'est j'ai envie de vous
dire le câlin le bien-être il ya une
bonne nouvelle dans la un hall a2 ou une
mauvaise nouvelle dans l'ain ou à deux
c'est à dire quelqu'un qui se fera faire
un vrai qu'à l'un et l'autre qui va se
prendre un cas un peu différente je ne
sais absolument pas je vous le jure ce
cas dans les cabines c'est à vous de
choisir ce que vous voulez à ça je vous
garantis que je ne sais rien je ne sais
pas qui a donc d'un côté vous allez
avoir un vrai beau calanques devrait
vous plaire
de l'autre j'ai peur que ce soit un peu
transpirant le câlin pour la tension
j'ai peur que ce soit ça que j'ai choisi
revoilà donc
je regarde la taille des cabines sauna
ne vous annoncer par deux donc vous
choisissez la deux nous allons aller
tous les deux devant puisque de toute
façon quand vous vous en prenez une moi
je prend automatiquement l'autre ouais
d'accord il a choisi la deux d'un côté
il y a le vrai qu'à l'un de l'autre côté
c'est top à la transpiration
merde au combat même en calabre je le
prends
cd
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mettez vous passez à la caméra parce que
c'est des moments privilégiés dans la
vie vous êtes père noël habituellement
je crois dans une boîte un strip tease
ou mesdames et messieurs nous avons jean
michel maire qui vient de nous rejoindre
j'avais glissement
[Musique]
offert ce qui vient de nous rejoindre
tout à l'heure jean michel a touché
quand on pige dans cette émission le
couperet tombe est la sentence suprême
on sort le déguisement de pouce à celui
bourreau de tous et ça me fait plaisir
de le revoir celui qu'on avait pas vu
[Rires]
alors le deuxième heure on va me donner
le thème du deuxième puisqu'on me donne
ce tableau c'est le verre niçois se voit
alors c'est quoi ça alors ces symptômes
liés
oui je suis d'accord pardon mais s'il
faut le net pour se protéger parce qu'il
faut se protéger parce que figurez vous
que dans là il y aurait non je puis deux
coupes de champagne d'accord et dans
l'autre donc c'est le thème s'élevèrent
et de notre serveur dans la gueule me
dit on ah bon donc quand même aller dans
tel quel ce truc ne sert absolument à
rien puisque vous ne tenez comme ça oui
bon d'accord très bien attention à
droite ou à gauche
verre de champagne ou coupent dans la
gueule ou si le contraire plutôt cool de
la gueule ouvert le champagne
arnaud oui tout un loisir peut-être
cette fois-ci oui avoue troisième rangée
sépare je vous en prie mais je vous
promets les noms parce que si je choisis
après veut dire je sais donc allez-y
choisissait je prends la deuxième et
sait pas il prend la 2 donc une coupe de
champagne ou à verre
bah la gueule qu'on ait beaucoup de
champagne maintenant à votre vie vous
qui avez tous expérience de l'émission
si je passe un extrait comme ça qu'est
ce que l'on a bien pu me demander de
vous demander derrière où est-ce qu'on
n'aime pas là alors le canapé le salon
vous êtes plutôt qu à vous isabelle
notamment de vous parler la salle de
mama c'est comme ça on est plus près de
la douche fa ses romans de la douche
froide bien à part ça agile la cuisine
qu'est-ce qui vous accident la cuisine
récep à l'eau qui coule le bruit de la
vaisselle le frigidaire à koné et
j'adore le bruit de la verrai pas ce que
vous lui fait de faire la vaisselle
pendant une fête de l'amour moi je
croyais que la vaisselle attend déjà les
mêmes lunettes parce que si jamais je
crois une terre dont la finalité est de
l'émoi en même temps record 2 3 merci
le corps mais le net une touche au donon
dur alors et vous nous avez dit oui peu
importe pourvu qu'il y ait une table à
il faut que ça donne une baisse ou une
autre une base une route sa dépense
moyenne par tout ça taille normale quoi
une table normal je préconise que l'on
arrête se tourner très rapidement j'ai
été jusqu'au bout de ce que je pouvais
faire vous assure j'ai tiré tiré amour
donner cette union se continuer une voix
la voix de la sagesse est en train de me
dire
passons à autre chose